[Musique]
jeu fédérer
mais sa première fois que je craigne que
cette colline que je vais rentrer dans
cet immeuble
premier jour de la nouvelle député à
ottawa
premiers pas dans un nouvel univers
qu'elle a hâte d'apprivoiser je porte
avec moi 120000 personnes pratiquement
qui m'accompagnent dans ce nouveau monde
donc je suis quand même le poids de la
responsabilité
en montant cette colline qui est
vraiment et collines
diplômé de l'université mcgill heather
tulk l'économiste participe à son
premier caucus bien décidé à changer le
monde en une opportunité unique
d'inclure tous les enjeux
environnementaux dans la relance
économique je suis économiste donc
évidemment
tout ce qui a trait à l'économie champ
que si je peux y contribuer à roscoe les
tchèques et loquace quand on a
seigneurie n'avait pas de galles la
députée parle couramment espagnol la
langue de sa mère péruvienne une avocate
et méritant l'immigration est une
féministe les paroles originales sont
sexistes ce que c'est un garçon qui
parle d'une fille en fait il dit qu'ils
sachent coudre et qu'ils sachent
cuisiner ou ma mère avait changé les
mots et qui avait changé les mots pour
qu'ils sachent écrire parce que ça rime
est sache écrire ils savent travailler
merci beaucoup de votre confiance
nathalie sinclair desgagnés est devenue
maman et député presque en même temps
une semaine après son accouchement elle
était déjà de retour au travail comme
nouvel élu est ce que je considère ça
comme un sacrifice je dirais non je suis
fier de représenter une tranche de la
population
et d'être une marque qui fait les deux à
la fois puis je sais qu'il va être
toujours être entre de bonnes mains j'ai
l'occasion de passer une année avec mon
petit garçon et des de nathalie à être
la meilleure député possible pour une
cause qui me tient énormément à coeur
est également indépendante du québec
s'est on s'est rencontré en militant
pour se
nathalie a grandi dans une famille très
politisée qui rêvait d'un québec
indépendant
à commencer par son grand père andré
desgagnés il enseigne et d'ailleurs à
lucien bouchard et je crois qu'il
enseigna vraiment mais aussi de mon
grand-père était candidat aux élections
du parti québécois en 1973 donc au
moment où il l'avait ouvert l'université
du québec à chicoutimi c'était premiers
lecteurs il a ensuite été candidat aux
élections 1973 dans dubuc donc juste à
côté de chicoutimi un grand père recteur
de parents qui se sont rencontrés au
doctorat à yale demain caucus toute la
journée nathalie desgagnés suit les
traces familiale après une maîtrise à
oxford elle travaille chez
pricewaterhousecoopers à londres puis
chez deloitte à montréal le choc de
rentrer à montréal de voir que
maintenant le français n'était plus une
exigence dans plusieurs emplois j'avais
des collègues qui ne parlait à peine
français puis ensuite de voir que à
montréal nos dossiers il y avait rien
important pour les gens de toronto
toutes les décisions étaient prises à
toronto et on nous faisait un signe de
ne pas intervenir pour moi ça a été un
choc parce que j'arrivais de gros
projets avec de gros dossiers
certaines compétences et je me retrouve
à montréal mais comme j'étais à montréal
ma voix n'était plus aussi écouter
travailler dans un grand cabinet conseil
demeure captivant pour la jeune
économiste jusqu'à la pandémie dans
l'ordinateur alors que des gens
souffrent à côté
ça j'étais complètement déconnecté
inaugurant matin je me suis dit coup
dont il faut que je fasse quelque chose
chez les saint clair de gagner le
sentiment nationaliste n'a d'égal que la
fibre socialiste le besoin d'aider son
prochain quand j'avais 11 ans j'ai fondé
ma mot propre charisme à but non
lucratif parce que maman m'avait
beaucoup parlé des enfants pauvres du
pérou la mer est enterré viennent j'ai
donc parrainé par pratiquement pendant
toute mon adolescence une école primaire
au pérou
alors envoyé des colis suspects
sont que ça quand même vous avez une
orientation à ma vie à mes choix de
carrière
natalia un espèce d'énergie
frondeuse fonceuse le chef du bloc
québécois annonce son cabinet fantôme
la député de terrebonne sera critique
des comptes publics et des programmes
liés à la pandémie dans la perspective
d'une longue carrière politique pour une
nathalie sinclair desgagnés je lui ai
dit et je le pense que c'est la grande
mêlée et science ça arrivera au bloc par
contre comment vous accueillez cette
nomination la madone 5h02 gagne avec
tout le poids des responsabilités que 5
à sac et ça inclut il va falloir
effectivement
que je pousse le gouvernement est le
plus transparents et rigoureux les
députés ravis de pouvoir mettre son
expertise au service des canadiens en
attendant de pouvoir le faire dans un
québec souverain toujours dans l'idée
qu'un jour je n'aurai plus à venir ici
parce qu'on sera un pays donc un jour
cette colline la jda a gravi les plus sa
voix que pays voisin et
[Musique]